Let's pray together over day 21.
Father, thank you for the assurance that all
things are right between us and you.
Thank you, Lord, for the confidence that we are given to Jesus by
God the Father, that we have obeyed the word of God, and that we
are not part of the world. We rejoice in that. We thank you for it.
We praise you that we have been cleansed.
We have been made clean by your word, by accepting it.
Thank you, Lord. Now, you bring us to an awareness
in this 40 days, you bring us to an awareness of
deeper cleaning. We don't want, Lord, to trust only
in what you have done for us in the past and to overlook things
that you still wish to do, that you still have
for us. When you have more for us, we don't want to just leave it on the
table. So God, we pray that you would clean not only our
consciences from dead works, but that you would clean
us in a deeper, more fundamental way.
We pray that your cleaning, your cleansing would go all
the way down to our hearts, to our
motivations, to our thought processes, to our
mindset. We ask, Lord, that you would, like
Peter talked about what happened in Acts 2, we pray, O
God, that you would clean us and purify our hearts
by faith. Jesus prayed that we would, who have been
cleaned, would be sanctified. And we pray that you would do this for us,
Lord, that you would sanctify those who have already been sanctified.
We pray that you would sanctify us in a deeper and more
fundamental and more powerful way.
Lord, would you draw to us, draw us to Christ,
and help us to rejoice in his purifying, sanctifying
work for us on the cross, and let all of the
results of that sacrifice be accomplished in our
hearts and in our spirits, we pray in Jesus'
name. Let's continue seeking the Lord together.